hey guys Pete here it's time for the
weekly spoiler report there's been a lot
of stuff going on in Spain this week and
there's been a ton of pictures making
their way to the Internet this is the
official spoiler warning if you don't
like to know what's happening behind the
scenes where cast members are or what
the actual filming is looking like for
the upcoming season then you won't want
to watch this video I do have a book
giveaway going on on my channel though
so watch one of my non-spoiler videos to
learn more about that everyone else
stick around to the end and let's jump
right into it so the hypes have been
building for several weeks about the
shooting going on around kasaa days
we've had a lot of shots of things being
set up and we had news last week about a
replacement for dick and Tarly this week
we've seen more pictures of Tom Harper
and James Faulkner together and we're
assuming that this means that Hopper
will play randyll Tarly son [ __ ]
Dicky and his Sam's little brother but
he was passed up to be the family heir
because well as we learned last season
Randall kinda hates Sam so even though
we did have a different actor played
dick and last season it looks like it's
been changed to Tom Harper fans caught
several pictures of the two together in
the streets and it really seems like
James Faulkner is a friendly guy who
does not mind getting his picture take
any ways they weren't there just for fun
they were actually filming and we know
that Jaime and Bronn were involved in
the scenes as well the news was that
there were hundreds of extras and Losey
a theory knows managed to record actual
shots of the filming taking place they
released two short videos that showed
the armies moving around early in the
week and reported that there were more
than 300 troops that were foot soldiers
and about 70 horses involved in the
scene they also said that the director
Matt Shaq Minh was spotted shooting a
sequence for Episode four of next season
at the same time they were shooting
Episode four large base camp of the
filming trailer showed up at low spar
echos I have to apologize to the
spanish-speaking fans out there I try my
best but I just really don't
have the language on top of the trucks
and other equipment lo cata Raynaud's
also spotted a giant green screen being
put up as part of the set remember
they're going to be there for three
whole weeks in this area and this is
going to be that big ambush scene so I
expect that will continue to see big
things
the next report came from the Spanish
publication el periódico extra Medora
they released a ton of photos which
appear to actually confirm all of what
we were talking about last week the
pictures show that there are horde of
Dothraki who are attacking those
caravans that were previously taken away
from Highgarden
it was the booty or the spoils of
sacking the Tyrell castle el periódico
externa Medora story is based on
eyewitness reports which we can see that
they're actually taking photos and can
see what's going on they're describing
the scene as an attack with a large
number of horses charging towards an
imaginary enemy but either way it's
imaginary for the moment since there's
going to be something else added in
later on Watchers on the wall printed
that los siete ara nose was able to
confirm a bunch of the other things that
we were talking about when it comes to
the ambush from last week basically the
Lannisters marching with the loaded
caravans and the Dothraki charging one
thing to note is that even though we've
seen Jamie Braun and the others in Spain
Emilia Clarke was actually spotted in
Belfast and at least up until this point
hasn't made it back to Spain yet on the
third day of photos getting out we got a
real upgrade to the quality we also got
some of the most interesting spoilery
stuff to talk about or speculate about
so this was probably the most exciting
day this week last week the photographer
Rick zarnow uploaded some good photos of
the crew getting ready and then this
week he added a bunch of stuff to his
Twitter account these are high-quality
images where you can make out a lot of
the different details related to the
cast and the set we also see a few green
screens in there which I guess would be
able to work for making the scenes with
even more soldiers and other special
effects that's
day another Twitter user named javi
released more pictures of the scene and
we can see randyll Tarly
and probably dick and Tarly on horseback
in one of the shots this is actually
interesting because their group of
soldiers are marching with the
Lannisters now think about it for a
moment the tarly's are pledged to house
Tyrell and we know at the end of the
last season that house Tyrell threw in
with Daenerys if the tarly's are now
marching with the Lannisters then that
means that there's been a betrayal so
it's been pretty usual this season that
will always see a lot more photos coming
out of Spain but that doesn't mean they
weren't shooting at all in Belfast this
week and even though we didn't get any
set shots we did get a lot of the cast
members out and about which gives us an
idea of who's going to be involved in
some of those scenes around Wolf Hill
quarry Emilia Clarke and Natalie
Emmanuel who played Daenerys and Miss
Andy put some pictures on Instagram
where they tagged the location as
Belfast we also got pictures of Sansa
Jorah Mormont
tormund and even one of Kit Harington
going to the dentist even though all
those people were there Sansa and
torment have already left the city and
been photographed elsewhere and there's
been photos of Davos being in Abu Dhabi
and it looks like Natalie Emanuel is
back in London we'll have to check back
next week to see if they go back to
Belfast or not high feet also put out
some more photos from his original ones
of the battle well we get to see the
Tarly forces a lot closer we can see for
sure that they're helping the Lannister
army out in a couple of these shots
which leaves no speculation about which
side they're on
lo ciento Raynaud's also put out a
couple more pictures that have really
great detail where we can see that
they're helping the Lannisters fortify a
shield wall but we can't tell what
they're defending or going up against we
don't see grey worm or any unsullied in
action in any of the shooting that's
happened yet but there have been
pictures of him showing up around town
this could be an indication that some of
the earlier reporting about the
unsullied not being involved in the
ambush scene was incorrect but of course
we're going to have to wait and see if
we actually see them in the back
before we can jump to any real
conclusions that's the extent of all the
new photos that we got this week but
don't forget there's going to be three
more weeks of shooting where we're going
to get a ton more stuff apparently the
days have been so long in the conditions
pretty dren Lluis because some of the
actors who are used for extras have
actually filed suit for not getting paid
overtime for 15 hour days they also
mentioned things like having rushed
lunch breaks and things like that so
that's awful if they have bad conditions
but it's probably going to be good for
us and that this scene is really going
to be as epic as the hype spent since
the Game of Thrones season 6 DVD set
came out last week they were holding
different events around the country and
Ellie Kendrick who plays Mira did an
interview with MTV was showed up in
vulture it's an interesting read where
she talks about the Starks and the
fierce loyalty that the reads have for
them she talks about her role as being
brans protector and nothing else in
other words she's not trying to guide
his story she's just there to make sure
nothing happens to him if she talks
about her love for brand story which is
pretty cool she says she loves the
storyline that he has because he's this
kid who's been forgotten but he has
these incredible powers to unleash she
said it reminds her of stranger things
and that you know he looks small and
weak but he's got this immense strength
and capability of mine and then the one
thing that she said that really stood
out to me was that's going to be one of
the most exciting things in the coming
episodes because he can reveal all of
the past and the future now that's a
pretty direct statement but I think it's
kind of vague at the same time if that
makes any sense the direct quote is he
can reveal all of the past and the
future
personally I don't take this literally I
think what it says as he can reveal as
in he can see different parts in time
because obviously one human being can't
process the entirety of the past and the
future I mean that's impossible
although they can pull out specific
events and important things that they
could be you know that they could be
shown in visions like we've seen bran do
in the past whenever he is connected to
the weirwood trees hopefully you guys
have all watched my brand videos
especially the last one I put it on
about as
importance and story I feel like this
interview just checks off one more box
and the brand is super important
checklist if you will overall it's a
really cool interview so you should
definitely check it out the final bit of
news is a pretty interesting little
tidbit from some of the pictures that we
actually saw last week I first saw this
on Twitter through the yeah Clark
Dragons daughter account but then later
Watchers on the wall mentioned it too so
at the filming we saw at Trujillo Castle
where they had all those shots on top of
the wall with the Lannister army and
their allies after they sacked
Highgarden
Adrian Alonso who just has a really good
eye I guess and recognized that Jaime
was carrying widow's wail which was the
Valyrian steel sword that Tywin had made
for King Joffrey
remember Tywin melted down how starts
Valyrian blade ice into two smaller
blades the first was for Jaime which
Brienne now has which we know as
Oathkeeper and the smaller of the two
blades was given to King Joffrey which
he named widow's wail so we could go off
the rail speculating here I mean Jaime
still doesn't have his original sword
hand but perhaps he's been practicing
and because of the smaller size he's
gotten pretty good with his left hand
I guess what the most exciting
speculation would be or should I say
sensational would be if we get to see
Brienne who's carrying the other half of
ice and Jaime locked in a battle where
the two swords go head-to-head
of course that's completely based off
the fact that they're on opposing sides
in the war and we definitely don't know
what's going to happen once the Seven
Kingdoms are faced with the true threat
which is coming from the north
so let me know what you guys think in
the comments about all these big battle
scenes shaping up are you surprised that
house Tarly turned its back on house
Tyrell remember the last time there was
an uprising against the crown in
Robert's rebellion the tarly's actually
remained loyal to the Targaryen so
historically this doesn't exactly make
sense which means that the Lannisters
must have offered them something that
was worth what basically amounts to
treason about going against their
leisure Lords please like the video if
you enjoyed it and make sure to follow
me on Twitter and all the other social
media accounts
you want to talk there as mentioned I do
have a book giveaway going on and all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video or any of the other videos where I
mention this giveaway when I reach 28
thousand subscribers I'll pick one
comment at random and I'll award that
commenter a free copy of the new 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
it's an illustrated edition and it's
really cool and you're definitely going
to want to have it to add to your
collection thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon